thank you guys all for coming out to the
online education
I'm Zach I'm going to talk a bit about
hacky Oh some things
done some things we want to do and some
things we've learned learned along the
way I know we ask this question earlier
but people were shy how many of you guys
are actually students hands super high
okay that's a lot that's awesome you
guys I think know at least as much as
the professor's do about how this stuff
can work so don't hesitate to get
involved and be bold about your opinions
and then how many you guys have heard of
hacky ale so I know okay cool that's
like two-thirds better than I expected
cool so what hacky Liz what we've
learned what we are is also what we hope
to do again this line broke there's no
space there but if you want to see the
talk go to hack he'll calm / PDF / what
is hacky all PDF I'll leave this on the
screen for a minute all the slides are
there and they are formatted nicely
because it has futuro I think it's
something else but anyway cool so I'm
Zack I'm the director of hacky L I've
been an instructor at HACC Yale for four
semesters now before that I was a
student I'm a senior in trumbull
majoring in computer science and econ
this summer I worked at Google in
Mountain View and i really like
slapstick comedy especially when it
involves martin lawrence any blue streak
fans not enough okay so hacky L through
the ages we provide student-run lectures
in web development introductory
programming and design to other students
so this is taught by students taken by
students we started in the fall of 2011
with a like flagship lecture course that
ended up being two seminars there was
huge demand from the start we had about
600 applications for the first course I
was one of the applications and I was
lucky enough to get in and I took the
first course which taught introductory
HTML CSS JavaScript and nodejs which are
programming languages you can use to
build websites so we considered
expansion after that fall we talked with
people at Harvard and Princeton and it
sort of became clear that we were best
off focusing on doing as good a job as
we could hear with the limit
man and woman power that we had
eventually we settled in as a provider
of educational cultural and professional
resources to yell students so what that
means is we have our flagship class I
teach that for the fourth time now it's
an introduction to front end web
development so learning how to build
cool websites that don't remember
anything about you and just show content
so similar to what we were talking about
with like a website that says what your
course is that would be an example we
have workshops this actually spun out of
a failed attempt to make more classes in
the second semester we had a rails class
Ruby on Rails an iphone app building
class and a node.js class in addition to
our front-end class and students were
really excited about that we got tons of
applications like yeah this is going to
be my biggest thing of the semester and
then people ended up not really being
able to commit and part of that is
because these topics are more esoteric
than the original flagship lecture class
so it's a little harder if you miss one
section it's much harder to catch up so
we decided that instead of devoting 10
weeks to these subjects will have
jumping off points of one to three hours
where you learn about the subject you
meet some people who are into it as well
and you get a starting point from which
you can go and learn on your own we
serve a function of publicity we have a
mailing list and about 1500 students
have signed up for it so whenever
there's a big tech event we help
publicize it we publicize our own
workshops and our class and then we
recently launched heck al jobs which is
a jobs board to connect startups and
students looking for jobs it's sort of
like UCS but for smaller companies who
don't have the man and woman power to
advertise on ucs or send recruiters here
and take students out to the study for
cocktails so we have our lecture it's
once a week we have office hours we have
homeworks we stay after and talk with
people we post our slides online you
know I don't know if you guys have read
about like the nine dimensions of
providing an education so we try to hit
as many of those as possible those being
like content professor student
interaction
although it is bold to call myself a
professor instructor student
interactions students student
interactions etc we try to do as much of
that as possible and we have a bunch of
cool websites that have come from the
students who took our class the yellow
Film Society website was built by becca
Edelman who was originally hacky ell
student she used it as her final project
for the class and some other ones cool
so the future we like two separate
things into like incremental change and
like moon shots which are like bigger
ideas that we're not working on already
so one we want to continue to try to
meet demand like I said we get between
three and six hundred applications for
our class each semester we can take
about 50 so that's not enough weed like
every student to have a chance and it's
really unfortunate when a student who
would really take it seriously and make
it their top priority doesn't get in
because everyone's going to say they're
going to make it their top priority jobs
and opportunities we want to keep adding
to our jobs board keep doing stuff there
I think we're doing a good job and then
our cultural presence it also has to do
with some of the stuff that was just
talked about in the open source platform
but we have a Twitter or Facebook enough
stuff to manage but it'd be nice to just
have even more things chronicling what
we're doing and helping get other people
involved and then moonshots so we've got
this Pacquio k-12 initiative it already
exists but what it is is I go to Metro
Business Academy which is a high school
down the road and teach a programming
class a couple times a semester and what
we really want it to be is more of a
presence the way that like chg or demos
or some other community service group on
campus has a presence in high schools
where we're involved in a lot of high
schools teaching programming having
individual interactions with kids and
trying to get as many younger kids
involved in programming as quickly as
possible because to be honest with the
introductory stuff they catch on just as
quickly as the Yale students and they're
a lot less afraid to make mistakes and
then the other thing which got deleted
from the slide is hack University that's
what I was talking about a bit when I
said we considered expansion we even had
we even like bought a camera and started
filming ourselves talking as professor
bloom
to an empty audience which is not the
most fun thing and so it's much harder
to do that and we realized that it
really requires a lot of work to create
custom content just to do that so it
never really came to anything but
interested to hear anyone's thoughts so
some learnings we've had and some
enduring mysteries so there are some
easy lessons a lot of these are specific
to teaching programming and specially to
teaching web development one of the
first lessons we had is we have to focus
on the products and what I mean by that
is we can't say oh hey guys like let's
learn about four loops this is going to
be so exciting we have to say no let's
learn about how to make this or have you
seen your news feed on facebook let's
figure out how that works putting things
in a real context that people can relate
to makes it much easier to get kids
excited about what we're doing maybe to
the contempt of some of my professors
and teachers in high school I've always
treated the teacher-student relationship
as one where the student is always right
you know I'm paying for an education
you're getting paid to give me one and
so if you're not doing in the way that's
working for me that's not my fault and
so we try to make on the other side of
the on the other side of the window as
teachers we try to hold ourselves to the
same standards and to say if the student
isn't extremely intrinsically interested
if the student doesn't love class every
day that's our fault and we need to
figure out how we can make that change
um so part of that is exuding passion
which is the other thing this does not
come naturally to me oh I'm normally
very quiet but one thing that I try to
do is show how excited I am about some
of these nerdy technologies and hope
that a little bit of that rubs off on
the students that we've had some some
non-obvious subtler lessons one thing
that wouldn't have occurred to anyone on
day one is that we should have class
when people aren't working our most
attended class in the history of hack
Yale is our friday afternoon section
it's very easy for students to say oh
it's a tuesday night i have business and
that i'm going to skip Pacquio when it's
less easy for students who are very
ambitious naturally to say oh it's a
friday afternoon i'm not doing anything
why shouldn't i be at hacky oh this one
might go over people's heads or under
people's feet
swag so you can define this as
confidence if you haven't turned heard
the word before but this is specific to
computer science a lot of people learn
one thing and then they they they don't
understand the next thing and they're
like oh shoot I'm not smart I can't
learn this the people who know this are
just smarter than me and that's not true
if other people have learned to do it
than you can too it's about ramming your
head against the wall until there are
cracks and then continuing around your
head against the wall until they're it
breaks down and then hoping you don't
have a concussion on the other side and
to do that you really need perseverance
drive and confidence the whole way you
need to feel like people have done this
so I can too and then when it comes to
instruction we prepare a ton of slides
we have these nice looking slides with a
clear outline of what seminar is going
to go like and then you know we're like
okay so last time we study this does
everyone remember what this is and it
was like no I forgot and so we have to
improvise on the day-to-day basis and
sort of avoid being a prepackaged set of
lectures as we put it earlier we haven't
really figured out how to ensure
long-term commitment I said that the
Friday afternoon class is our best
attended lecture or seminar today but
it's still not that great I think
everyone who's dealt with huge online
courses I don't know if you guys read
that fast company article I don't know
if you agreed with the journalistic
integrity of it but if you did get a
chance to read it one thing that stood
out is that the completion rates for a
lot of these classes to start that high
and with hack yell when we have full
time students who are devoting their
free time of this that's obviously a
huge problem for us to and something
that we're working really hard to solve
and holding ourselves to the standard
and it's our fault and then we need to
bite off the right amount for our class
the first time that we taught it we try
to do the front end technologies and
then also a back end in know Jas and it
was just a little bit too much so we've
scaled back to front end stuff but we're
still figuring out exactly what the
right balance is especially when we have
a class of some people who have
programmed before some people who have
no experience and some people who are
entering their fourth year as a computer
science major and we're still working on
swag no one's no never
ending battle cool so I prepared some
homework for you guys today if you want
to brag about how you've done it you can
send me an email with a screenshot of
the completed project that is not
necessary so homework number one is to
complete project one at dash general
assembly the URL is a little difficult
for people who are not as literate with
the internet but my general assembly as
a start-up in New York it was started by
some Yale graduates Matthew Brymer and
Brad Hargreaves and they have a new
product called dash which teaches
introductory web development from a very
product focus side if you guys have used
code Academy before it's a fantastic
platform but it is more of a programming
teacher than a product building teacher
and I really like how this takes an
approach of building products from day
one and also go ahead and play around
with a demo at hacky o intro heroku com
it's a little demo that I put together
for you guys so that you can understand
a little bit more about what I mean when
I say HTML versus CSS versus JavaScript
it takes you through what the three
technologies mean and then gives you a
little demo to play around with at the
end thank you guys so much for listening
to me air my thoughts and if you have
any more questions you can email me at
zac attack yell calm or if you didn't
get anything that I've said I'm happy to
define it for you